foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing plot holes big and small from
the Chamber of Secrets book the second
book from the Harry Potter series is
filled with fine little inconsistencies
that fill its pages from the strange
fate of the Basilisk to the bizarre
behavior of the professors the Chamber
of Secrets has no shortage of potential
plot holes that we can chat about in the
comments below so today we're going to
dive head first into that old book and
take a look at some of my favorite plot
holes big and small that have often
thought about over the years why didn't
they clean up the Chamber of Secrets the
Basilisk is one of the most dangerous
creatures in the entire Wizarding World
when compared to other beasts like
acromantulas and Giants the Basilisk was
actually far worse to show you just how
dangerous they are an average wizard
would have a better chance surviving a
fight with a Hungarian horntail than
these serpent that herpo the fowl first
created and it makes sense if you think
about it just one glance from a basilisk
was enough to stop your heart that meant
you had to fight with your eyes closed
how many creatures would be able to
trade blows of the Basilisk if they were
robbed of their sight and the giant
Serpent's fangs excreted the most vile
poisonous venom that any magical
creature could produce
so you have to wonder why didn't Albus
Dumbledore clean up the remains of the
Basilisk after Harry Potter slayed it at
the end of the Chamber of Secrets its
rotten corpse was more than an unsightly
display every inch of the Basilisk was a
precious ingredient that any dark Wizard
or angsty student would love to retrieve
for their potions can you imagine all of
the dark hexes and curses at a single
drop of Basilisk Venom could create and
let's not forget that the Chamber of
Secrets was created by Salazar Slytherin
in the first place furthering created
the chamber and left the Monstrous
basilisk behind in protest of his other
co-founders who had refused to follow
his lead in Banning muggleborn students
from attending Hogwarts why didn't
Dumbledore and the rest of Hogwarts
staff March into the chamber and clear
it of all dark relics moaning Myrtle's
parents when discussing the tragic death
of Moaning Myrtle and Tom Riddle
bemoaned the fate of her parents her
poor mother and father who had never
considered the risk of their daughter
face at Hogwarts would be forced to
visit Hogwarts and attend their own
daughter's funeral but there was a
problem with that Hogwarts famously
never allowed Muggles to step foot on
its campus which meant Myrtle's parents
shouldn't have made the [ __ ] so how did
they of all the theories on the internet
the most compelling one was pretty
simple maybe the Headmaster of the time
made an exception of course Tom Riddle
attended Hogwarts decades before Albus
Dumbledore was ever promoted so the
Headmaster of the time must have been
Armando deped as one of the oldest
Wizards to hold the title and one
particularly fond of rules it's unlikely
that deped would have allowed Myrtle's
parents in how did the Basilisk survive
and while we're talking about the
Basilisk have you ever wondered what it
ate since it was supposedly locked
within the chamber throughout its 1000
year lifespan what could it have eaten
in order to survive so long when
thinking about this question you might
be tempted to chime in with a few
obvious answers typically man-made
structures quickly become home to pests
like mice and rats but would that have
been enough to sustain the Basilisk even
during Harry Potter's second year there
were no recorded deaths and no students
were eaten and students certainly seem
like the most likely source of
sustenance and the otherwise Barren
Castle an easy way to fill this plot
hole is to assume that a large magical
rodent-like creature also resided in the
Chamber of Secrets with so much water
and waste flowing around it wouldn't be
Unthinkable for nests of giant rats to
cool the chamber their second home but
of course herb of the fowl the
terrifying dark wizard who first
successfully bred basilisks never told
us how often and how much they needed to
eat for some more developed theories
addressing us check out my longer video
on the subject before Minerva McGonagall
putting students lives at risk Professor
Minerva McGonagall was always one of the
most even-headed instructors at Hogwarts
but during one of the basilisks attacks
she made an uncharacteristically foolish
mistake while Harry Potter was out and
about Hardin thought while on the
quidditch field the professors at
Hogwarts discovered there had been
another attack just like they always
seem to do the faculty quickly decided
that the safest thing was to whisk all
the students back to their dorms and
shut the doors behind them and it was
Professor McGonagall who gave the order
but if you just give this a second of
thought you'd see just how foolish this
was the Basilisk traversed Hogwarts by
scaling the vertical pipes within the
school's walls and it never really
seemed to venture out into the school's
grounds that meant these students were
far safer when they were away from the
school then when they were confined find
within then why did such a sharp-minded
professor like the conical Usher them
all back to their dorms 3. Valentine's
Day do you know which day of the week
Valentine's Day 1993 fell on no of
course you don't and when JK Rowling was
putting the finishing touches on Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets it
seems like she had no clue either
because during the events of that
fateful school year she clearly depicted
all the students of Hogwarts attending
their classes as if it were any other
day but Valentine's Day 1993 was
actually on a weekend Sunday to be exact
unless Headmaster Albus Dumbledore was
feeling especially cruel he wouldn't
have called the students to attend
classes on the weekend but instead of
dismissing this as a simple editing
mistake I think it's more interesting to
consider what type of plot holes this
opens why were the students in class and
what could it mean surely together we
can do more than enough meant gymnastics
to figure out a solution that doesn't
break Harry Potter Canon for my money
I'm betting that the Weasley twins Jinx
the calendars causing everyone to go to
class as normal the basilisks hissing we
all know that only parcel tongues can
communicate with serpents that fact
remains true of basilisks too which is
why Harry Potter was the only one who
could hear the faint Whispers in the
walls during his second year at Hogwarts
but throughout Harry's time at Hogwarts
Ron and Hermione had the chance to
observe him speaking parcel tongue more
than a few times and during those
interactions they very clearly could not
only hear Potter's bizarre speech but
the snake's own hissing as well but
throughout their second year when
Hermione and Ron were close to Harry
they seemed to be oblivious to the very
large hissing snake that was somewhere
nearby climbing up the ancient leaky
pipes behind the brick walls you might
be be tempted to quickly sweep this plot
hole into the rug by pointing to Harry's
telepathic-like connection to snakes or
you might claim that snake hissing seems
to be Amplified for parcel tongues all
that might be true but it's certainly
inconsistent for Ron and Hermione to
hear the hissing at some times and at
others hear nothing at all some simple
math when we look at plot holes within
the Chamber of Secrets it's easy to try
and brush them under the rug and find a
reason for their existence and I suppose
that's all part of the fun for example
when we wonder why the Basilisk didn't
more aggressively Target Harry earlier
we can find any number of reasons namely
Voldemort's own vanity but when it comes
to this particular plot hole I think
that the truth is the numbers just don't
add up within the Chamber of Secrets
Lord Voldemort made a small mistake when
trying to belittle James and Lily
Potter's sacrifice the dark wizard
claimed that the parents death sent
shorty measly 12 years of peace and
quiet for their son but if Voldemort had
studied a bit harder in math class he
would have realized that it had only
been about 11 years since the Fateful
night he had first tried to kill the
Potter boy plot hole or mistake whatever
the case may be this fun little
inconsistency is one that opens up a
treasure Trove of topics for debate well
there you have it seven plot holes big
and small from the Chamber of Secrets do
you have any theories that will clear
these amp make sure to let me know in
the comments below and if you have any
fun plot holes that you found on your
own make sure to share those as well
after all we barely scratched the
surface of the bug there's plenty more
where these came from also be sure to
check out my other videos covering plot
holes until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
foreign